復活してから結構日にちが経ちましてようやく僕もだいぶユーチューバーっぽく戻って
きたわけなんですけどもうちょっと
大事なんだぜいいかな大事な話かわかんないんですけどもう僕が復活ツールで際に一つ
言ったことがあると思いますか
かっこいいでしょ復活する内に人といったことだったと思うんですけれどもこうなんて
言ったっけなんて言ったら
忘れちゃったなぁそれでもねあの一人でやっていく自信がない的な事を言ったと思い
ます
切ってからも1か月ぐらいを断ってるのは浅尾と言ったことの意味としてはまあ一人で
中止するまで
ガーンとやってきたんですけども静岡東京間を行き来している間にいろんなことを
こなしているうちに
これこれ多分一人では無理だなと思ってそのぞ東京に行ってる間動画撮れないんですよ
落ち着いてなんか静岡で一人で落ち着いて撮りたい人間だったんですけどもそれは無理
だと思って結構飽きられてた時とかあってそれでもやっぱ東京に行かなきゃいけない
から
ん
まあ言うたらもうほぼ無理矢理奪ってねちょっと自分の中で妥協したりして動画を撮っ
て編集してアップしたりって言うほんとなんというかとても楽しかったんですけど
もっとなもっとこう時間の欲しいなって思ってることが qc 前からずっとありまし
てそういう意も込めて一人でいく自信がないと復活するために言いました
今僕は一人
やっている訳じゃなくて前にも言ったんですけども友達が一人お手伝いというか
サポートできてくれてて動画の時は正木ヶ浜に出てくれたり後輩が手伝ってくれたりし
て動画をやってるんですけども今後ちょっとどうしていこうかという中で僕お休み中に
一つ
閉め事をしておりまして今回その約束事
救出日目だ一つをちょっと皆さんに
秒しようと思っていたところなんですけども動画のタイトル見ればわかりますね
新メンバーがあります
[音楽]
代打とずっと一人でどうやっているように見えますけども
動画を始めた時はグループでやってました実は今更ながら恥ずかしいんですけどはじめ
カンパニーというふざけた名前で何人かの友達で最初は youtube やってたん
ですけどもやる気がなくなったメンバーがいたり彼女との揉み合いで辞めたメンバーが
いたリコーいろんなことがあって結局僕が一人ブラ成功雅紀が手伝ってくれるっていう
感じ
まで来たんですけども元例えば僕ってみんなで撮り動画が実はスタートだったんですで
今回新しく入るメンバー
いうのは
匠副社長という形です
知ってるもうこれ知ってるかしてないか不安なんですけども2年前ぐらいまでいたん
ですよ今も就職しちゃってお金を自分の蜜を言ってたんですけどもいろいろ僕が話し
まして編集やもう友達がいるんですけど撮影でちょっと一人だと辛いときがあるなとか
忙しすぎという見解をちょっとパンツたりしているっていう事を相談した結果
もうそんな簡単に決めたわけですよ
色々話しましたからすごい色々話した結果
彼が戻ってきます俺がもう戻しました一緒に頑張っていこうということで新メンバーと
して戻ってくることになりますちょっと本人いなくて申し訳ない
もうちょいおおおっ
もうます混ぜこんばんわっはっはー
そんなんは仕事にさせるのは仕事ですか排泄に出張でございますあ全長8避ける
匠さんよはい入居言ってしまってるんやー
お前は
加工なるような気が続いてよ
なあ
本当はね本当はでは本当はこう一緒に youtube やっていきたかったけど
なかなかこう誰かをな人生はそれを自身もなくてよなかなか誘えなかったんだけど
[音楽]
など熱帯
卒業せて会社に内定だってあって再販さん
内諾をたずに行く時から一緒に
将来どうなるんだろうねダラスながら来てって
何トラクターの時からこんなギターいつか来るんじゃないかなってずっととっては行っ
て
2でがあったり今の仕事も凄い凄い人たちに書かれてたし
チャートないようむ結構好きだったし
そうでもやっぱり
[音楽]
今回に誘われたとき
学園だろうん聞いた山間から心は決まっていたところ買ってっ
[音楽]
これから一緒に頑張っていきますそう
宜しくお願いしますした
こそようこそですいやー
もんでもねぇ進んでくるとやっぱこう1提案することだかねサー
何が起こるかわかんないかな+かにわからない何かあったときは3何度かせようぜ
なんだっていいっ
謎解きと
ウエタツならなんとかできるようだいげふ来月れないだけ
えっ
9分の1になるという日は072
57月に入ったお姉ちゃんて止まってるよねが皆様に一言
皆さん入ったことです下手ですね
減税分
はいというわけでですね高み複雑が帰ってきますその月も
彼の人生を
せようと言っても過言ではないからプレッシャーがすごいのはまあ正直なとこなんです
けども今後
俺は一体どうしたらいいんだろうということを色々考えだから動いてたんで
また今後でちょっといろんな動きがあるかもしれないので各3と将生と周りの人達で
頑張っていければいいなと思っておりますそんな感じ
丸に助けられながらみんなで協力してまあ無理せず結構て杖とか正直したくない
から得るべく被りしない感じねちゃんと対処に気を使っても死んだら元も子もないけど
無理せず楽しく youtube やっていければいいなと思ってこういう決断に至り
ました
まだちょっといろんな変化があると思うので是非皆さんお楽しみにじゃん
me
あっはぁ